Hey everyone, how's it going? My name is Mayuko. So
a big theme for me, my content, my channel, is about staying
in touch with my Japanese roots. So I've made videos like
these before. But being both Japanese and American and a
software engineer, one such thing that I've started to
explore more recently is the intersection between Japan and
technology. Because in my life, those two circles have only
barely just overlapped before. You see, I've never like,
lived nor worked in Japan for like a meaningful enough
amount of time. But I often wonder what would have happened
if I did, because there's totally a universe in which I did.
Like maybe I want to go work in Japan after college or my
parents just like, move back to Japan after they had me.
Either way, I am who I am now. I spent the majority of my
life in America and I'm pretty familiar with what it's like
to work as a software engineer in Silicon Valley. But this
alternate universe, this like, life that I could have had
left me thinking, what is the Japanese tech scene like? I
think most people think that people in Japan, and like Japan
itself, is a country that like lives in the future. And that
might be because a lot of us remember what the world was
like in the 80s and 90s, when Japan dominated technology and
electronics with things like Walkmans and TVs and DVD
players and Honda cars. But what happened? It just feels
like there's this huge gap between technology from Japan in
like the 80s and 90s to now in 2021. How did Japan fall
behind? And what challenges does a face currently? And what
are they doing right now to address it? And you know, being
a YouTuber, I was kind of like, maybe I should make a video
about this. Soooo here we go. Oh, quick note. By the way, a
lot of the comparisons that I'm going to make in this video
are between Silicon Valley in Japan because Silicon Valley
is what I know. So this isn't meant to be like an objective
analysis of what happened. I'm just sharing what I learned
from talking to some folks and reading articles and stuff
and so I will link those articles in the description box
down below if you'd like to learn more. I also want to note
that I'm not judging like any person or company or country
or anything like that, like I don't think there's like a
good or bad, I just wanted to know what IS. So yeah, I'm
just telling you my very subjective thoughts, and with that
PSA out of the way, now we can go! So, What's your
impression of Silicon Valley?
Mayuko: And what's your impression of the Japanese tech
industry?
Yuka: What Japanese tech meant to me it was definitely like
hardware so like Sony, Panasonic, Toshiba. All those
companies were like, really cool. And I really liked like,
audio stuff or like TVs and those were always Japanese
brands when I was growing up. Now I think a lot of Japanese
tech companies are definitely looking at companies in
Silicon Valley to learn from
Mayuko: So in order to start talking about this, we always
got to start with taking a little look back into history and
in this case, Japanese history.
Okay, but Japan's history is LONG. So this is going to be
one of the most like, shortened versions of it based on the
things that I found on the internet. Before World War Two,
Japan was going through an era called the Meiji Restoration.
This united the country under the Emperor Meiji with
strengthened it through its unification and basically
started Japan's Industrial Revolution. Before this era,
Japan was in a period called "sakoku" or like, closed
borders. So they didn't trade or talk to really any foreign
countries, except for a very small few. And so just like,
foreign influence just didn't happen in Japan for many, many
years. So because they weren't receiving any influence, they
were just like, behind in many aspects compared to the rest
of the world. Mind you. This is like the 1800s. So it really
wasn't that long ago. Well, this industrialization led to
militarization of Japan, which then led to World War Two,
which then they of course lost. After a period in which they
needed to rebuild their nation, they experienced just like
such a huge economic boom, which basically got them to have
one of the highest GDP per capita in the world. And this is
after the Japanese economy shifted its focus from things
like agriculture and mining, to telecommunications and
computers. This was when Japan had his technological
revolution, in my opinion. So much so, that in 1990, six of
the world's top 10, semiconductor companies were Japanese.
Intel actually ranked fourth between Japanese companies NEC,
Toshiba, and Hitachi. So yeah, Japan basically had like huge
ups and downs to ride in the 18th and 19th century. But now
when we think about the 21st century, when we think about
like, what technologies and tech companies are changing the
world, we often think about Silicon Valley and FAANG. And in
the meanwhile, there's many headlines about how Japan is
falling behind, especially in technology. So what happened?
So based on what I knew about Japan, I had a few guesses.
Firstly, I realized that the whole like Japan's living in
the future thing was not rooted in anything actually
technologically revolutionary. It instead was rooted in
convenience, and sharing a common set of values because of
how homogenous society was. So things like pristine
convenience stores and on time trains. And, like, you know,
when you go up an escalator in Japan, everybody stands on
one side together to allow the passer bys to go up. I think
all of that is the whole living in the future thing, but
it's just convenience. So then I thought about the working
culture, there's tons of videos and articles that talk about
the intensity of the work culture in Japan, one that kind of
like, even puts American Hustle culture to shame. (Not that
anyone should like have that title, or that's something to
like, fight for her or anything like that). But things like
overtime, poor work life balance, and a really rigid
hierarchical structure are things that I've heard about time
and time again. They were all in the context of Japanese
cultural values. So things like "meiwaku wo kakenai", like
don't burden others, to being afraid of failure, as well as
risk aversion. Now, I'm not like a sociologist, or an
anthropologist, by any means. So I don't know where these
values came from. But these are ones that I've seen in my
own life, and I've seen echoed by other Japanese people that
I know. And I can totally see how all that impacts Japanese
working culture. So was that it? Was it the working culture?
Was that why ever since software and the internet started
dominating the world, Japanese products and services have
become increasingly absent from our lives? Well, what I
learned is that Japan just didn't adapt to software as well
as other places had, because Japan thought of software as
second class. Okay, this one blew my mind because like,
software engineers are like the new doctors and lawyers like
the 2010s and 2020s.
Eric: Like in America, there's like a lot of prestige that
comes with being a software engineer, like software
development is not really super respected as a career, it's
more like something that's meant to be outsourced. And that
you do for kind of a few years before becoming a manager,
like a product manager or consultant or something like that.
It doesn't have like the prestige we have in the US, I would
say, in the US, you know, when you say you're a software
developer, people are like oh, wow, cool, you know what I
mean? Here (Japan), it's like, Oh... I see... there's still
that image, it's like this blue collar job. At a lot of
places where again, the goal is to kind of do it for a
little while, and then go on to something better. And you
kind of like pay your dues as a programmer.
Mayuko: Because Japanese manufacturers still held power in
Japan over the last 30 years. There is this bias that
hardware is first class. Because unlike software, it was
something that you could see and touch.
Kenji: My main point is that Japanese big companies were
putting the software people in the second class, the first
class people are hardware. Those who are doing "monozukuri",
or those who are creating actual things, not bits. It's
tangible. Those things have to be tangible.
Mayuko: For a country that's still very true to like its
craftsmanship roots, this made a ton of sense to me. Japan
still prides itself in its handmade and multi generational
crafts. Like in America, like stationery stores and
bookstores are like all the disappearing. And that's kind of
true Japan as well, but like they still sell lots of paper
calendars at the stationery store. And I think that's part
of this bias towards like analog products and like paper.
And I mean, like regardless of if you're Japanese or not,
concepts that are ambiguous, like the ones that you can't
like engage all of your senses in like you can't see and
touch and smell it and stuff can be difficult to grasp. So
this bias against software basically led to low salaries and
poor stock options in tech companies. And adjacent to that
are labor laws in Japan. They make it really hard for
companies to fire or lay off its employees, which you know,
is great for job security, like Silicon Valley definitely
can't offer that level of job security to anyone. But that
basically creates a lack of a pool of senior talent. And so
companies aren't even really like trying to like hire like
great people, I guess. So they're not going to offer things
like better benefits or like better projects, because most
of the hiring that they're doing is straight out of college.
And so as a result of all of this, like Eric mentioned,
software is something that is seen to be outsourced to
someone else because of its second class state.
Of course, while all this is happening in Japan, and
companies like Google, Apple and Facebook, were taking the
world by storm in America. Silicon Valley charged forward in
creating products and services and companies and
technologies that would basically define how technology is
made. And at this point, I think Japan kind of knew that was
like, on the downhill, you know, like birth rates are
declining, and the population is aging. And there wasn't
anybody who could compete with any of these big Silicon
Valley tech giants. But in the middle of this, there was one
company that everybody I talked to said change the game in
terms of technology in Japan, that company was mercari, or
merukari. Mercari is a marketplace app where you can buy and
sell your own belongings. And it was Japan's very first tech
unicorn. And that basically means it was the first company
that was valued at over $1 billion. They actually IPO'd in
2018. And it went really well. And so because they were the
very first tech unicorn,  this was a huge deal. From the
folks that I've ever talked to about Mercari, they think
that one of the things that really helped them to be
successful was that it did its business in kind of an
unconventional way, compared to Japanese business standards.
Specifically, a lot of their culture and policies emulated
Silicon Valley startups. So things like better pay and
better stock options, and even like a mixed language
environment. So you can speak either English or Japanese
anywhere. And so from what I can tell, the tech industry in
Japan really kind of started there. After Mercari, a ton of
new startups started sprouting up in Japan, specifically in
the Tokyo area that also emulated Silicon Valley companies
that allowed for a more flexible working environment. And
this only happened like three years ago. So I think it just
took Japan a little bit of time to figure out what worked
for them. But of course, challenges still lie ahead for
Japan's tech economy.
While there's more new tech startups in Tokyo than ever
before, and high schoolers and middle schoolers in Japan
want to be a software engineer more than anything else,
that's just not the whole picture. There's still a big part
of the industry that follows the old practices of treating
software as second class. So until there's just like a large
enough shift towards more equitable and flexible working
conditions, it just doesn't breed a ground for innovation.
Eric: Just as a career, it's not as established. But that's
starting to change, I think. And that also goes back to the
education as well, like the CS programs are generally not
really up to the level that you would expect in the US and
other places, unfortunately. I think that's starting to
change. There's more talk of like helping, you know, younger
kids learn about programming and that kind of thing, really,
just in the past couple of years.
Mayuko: And the other thing that every person that I talked
to said is a challenge for Japan, in many different ways is
diversity.
Kenji: They have to look like you or me to be accepted as a
normal citizen. And that kind of unification, or a lack of
diversity in general, in Japan, is the one of the reasons
why we failed to adapt.
Yuka: In the beginning where people were talking about
diversity. They're like, are we lowering the bar? When we
try to hire for diversity and those kind of like, FAQ stuff,
which is already debunked in the US. There's like proof that
that is not the right questions to ask is still being asked
in Japan.
Mayuko: I mean, Japan is, let's just say it, a pretty
homogenous society. Japan's always had difficulty in
accepting and celebrating people from all different
backgrounds. And there's definitely like a bias towards like
domestic products and services in Japan than international
ones. But Japan does want to globalize and participate in
the global tech economy. And so in participating in a global
economy, you know, in places like Silicon Valley, which
definitely has its own issues with diversity and inclusion,
we just know that diversity is a key ingredient to
innovation.
I just think that like new perspectives and ideas
and thoughts that come from lots of different kinds of
people from different genders and races and many more
dimensions is exactly what will help Japan to figure out how
it will play a part in the global economy. So how might they
address this with regard paving the road for other it and
tech startups to thrive? What can Japan do? Mind you, change
takes a long time to happen in Japan, like way longer than
America. Like we could wait for attitudes about software and
diversity to change in a meaningful way across the country.
But I just don't think Japan works that way in the same way
that America does. But Japan is fully committed to doing
something about it. On Japan's official website, they commit
to... So what can they do to invite new ideas and boldly go
where they haven't gone before?
Well, Japan's Ministry of Internal Affairs and
communications got involved, they partnered with a Japanese
Think Tank company called KADOKAWA ASCII Research Lab
Incorporated to figure something out. And I partnered with
them on this very video to talk about the INNO-vation
program. They've been doing this program for like eight
years now. And last year, they went global. So now they
invite anyone from anywhere in the world to participate.
Okay, so I was ecstatic when they reached out to me, because
I felt like this is a really good opportunity to really
explore what's happening in technology in Japan. And also, I
think this is genuinely such a unique kind of program that
really responds to all the things that we were talking
about: it invites new voices in, and it promotes people to
not be afraid of failure and to take risks. And by making it
like very big official thing, it gives software and
technology the sense of prestige that it needs, which
thereby raises the status of people in technology in Japan.
Every year, the program hosts different challenges that are
aimed at bringing forth different kinds of ideas. The first
is the Disruptive Challenge. It invites anyone to submit
their ideas to get funding for their inventions. Kind of
like if you wanted to like make a thing, you have a great
idea, but you want to get funding for it to make it a real
thing. winners of this challenge get up to 3 million yen, or
that's about $30,000 in support to work on their idea. And
graduates from this program, one year later, could get
things like exhibitions, patents and media promotions and
stuff. The Generation Award similarly invites new ideas and
technologies and techniques that help humanity to take a
leap forward in unexpected ways. This one gets evaluated by
corporate partners of the program, who then match with you
to make your idea a reality. Both of these challenges don't
require you to have like already made something because what
they're doing is investing in the potential of your idea,
which I think is so cool. Also, the judges for this program
are really cool. There's like the founder or Ruby, the
programming language on the panel, as well as many other
really influential people in technology in Japan, all really
wanting to help kickstart Japan's tech economy. They also
have the INNO-network hub, which is a network of cooperative
partners in 53 locations globally. This hub connects
institutions to support innovative ideas happening in and
outside Japan. So it's meant for businesses, enterprises,
and institutions who are looking to get involved. But yeah,
Japan, through this program, really is putting in the money,
time, and effort where they need to, and they're looking for
people from everywhere to help them boldly go where they
haven't go ne before. So yeah, if you're interested in the
program, or any of the challenges, then all the links are in
the description box down below so you can find out more. I
genuinely think it's such a cool opportunity to get to be a
part of something so big like this, and have the opportunity
to work with people in and outside of Japan to figure out
what comes next in technology. So anyway, thank you so much
for watching today's video. I genuinely had such a fun time,
like learning and researching and talking to all different
kinds of people to learn about the tech industry in Japan.
And honestly, I'm just like really excited to see what
happens. I just think like between the rising startup scene
in Japan and Tokyo and things like the INNO-vation program,
we can really only expect great things to happen. So thank
you so much to the folks that I interviewed for this video,
and thank you so much for watching, I typically don't make
these kinds of videos, but if you like it then let me know
in the comments down below and what topic you'd like to see
me cover. Don't forget to subscribe to this channel because
I'm almost half a million subscribers, and it'd be really
cool to get there. And if you're already subscribed, thank
you and if you're not, subscribe! Alright everybody, I'll
see you next time. Take care. Bye!!!